but first up he is the editor-in-chief
of WikiLeaks who comes to us from the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London Julian
Assange Julian great guys hey how you
doing Julian great to see you again I
know there's gonna be a bit of a delay
like in your life but you're back in the
news of course because WikiLeaks
released thousands and thousands of
emails from the Democratic National
Committee right before the Democratic
convention and you of course in the past
have released lots of documents from
governments but people questioned
whether this was fair game because the
Democratic National Committee is not a
government it's private and some of the
donors had their social security numbers
and credit card numbers released do you
think this is fair game well it was
definitely good fun fair game well we
didn't think we did the same thing to
send to Norm Coleman's campaign
Republican senator back in 2009 are the
Turkish political party AKP just the
other week a neo-nazi party here in the
UK a few years ago I remember the name
of it a irritating party British
National Party so no I think it's I'm
super happy with how that's gone we've
had four people in the DNC resign W
Wasserman Schultz they had the chief
financial officer the communications
director Lewis Miranda etc and that
shows a kind of instant accountability
perhaps not proper political
accountability for a a really quite
concerted effort through the chain of
command at the DNC to make sure that
Bernie Sanders didn't win including by
pumping out black PR well I don't know
if that's really true I mean I read
those emails there was no smoking I do
well I know that it's true
communications director Louis Moran the
communications director Louis Miranda
who has resigned just three days ago
instructed his staff in instruction not
a discussion and instruction to pump out
quote in an unattributable manner
statements and an article saying that
Bernie Sanders supporters were engaged
in acts of violence so this is the DNC
demonizing in a covert manner through
its chain of command to the press and
it's its favorite press contacts a
Democrat saying a Democrat was
conducting violence when you have the
Trump at the same allegations against
the Trump campaign they're there by
watering down the critique against the
Trump campaign and of course pumping up
that why ever why are we seeing anything
hacked from the Trump campaign I mean
obviously we know these came from Russia
and we also know that you do not like
Hillary Clinton at all as does not blood
a mere Putin so it looks like you are
working with a bad actor Russia to put
your thumb on the scale and basically
[ __ ] with the one person who stands in
the way of us being ruled by Donald
Trump
justify hanging yeah we thought we'd do
a little search on our files and I do
notice that a William Maher gave a
Clinton affiliated entity million
dollars now it's it's a William Maher in
LA where that at the time Annie came
perhaps you would like to comment is
that you yeah yeah I don't think you
have to look in your files to find that
Julian I
I gave Obama a million dollars I made it
public I the whole point of it was to
make it public so that people in 2012
would understand that the game had moved
to the million dollar level after our
Citizens United ruling I wasn't trying
to hide it I was trying to publicize it
I don't know what the point is is is
there another million dollars going to
Hillary or or equivalent [ __ ] no but no
no I can't give a million dollars every
time somebody runs through
for president but okay hey I could
understand 2012 I won't judge sure about
that but okay let's let's tackle these
criticisms we did not publish for credit
card numbers about donors it's the last
four digits just like your 7-eleven
receipt it's very important for tracking
money-laundering and there are serious
allegations of money laundering and FEC
violations that data released our
materials the materials that we release
are pristine
we're really good at this we have a ten
year perfect record of having never got
it wrong in relation to the integrity of
what we've released there's no
allegation even even from debbie
Wasserman Schultz or any of these people
that any of the materials are completely
valid and true what there is is a
conflation between our publications DNC
leaks and an extensive variety of hacks
of the DNC and frankly other
organizations over the last two years
possibly by state actors that wouldn't
be at all surprising but also a number
of others DNI clapper the head of all US
intelligence agencies James clapper said
last Friday that the media was
hyperventilating they couldn't make an
attribution let alone as the motivation
and even that was just about the hacks
is not about the material we released
but we know the source of the material
right everyone knows the source of what
ray published what is their Democratic
Party the source is but Louis Miranda
docile in shorts et cetera et cetera all
right I know I know you're I know
defended atheists but I included in
there by the discussion with luis
miranda is a plot a plot to frame bernie
sanders as being an atheist well then
and not as being jewish first of all it
wasn't a plot somebody mentioned it and
nobody did anything about it let's move
on to the other part we don't we don't
know whether people did anything about
it or not what we know was
a discussion okay you find me down we
can separate it a bit you can separate a
little bit of other case that I
mentioned before where Luis Miranda gave
an instruction to stop comes out black
propaganda against Bernie Sanders all
right so why don't you why don't you
hack into Donald Trump's tax return
well we're working on it
all right I mean it's interesting
because Edward Snowden criticized you
I mean his tweet was democratization
democratizing information has never been
more vital and WikiLeaks has helped and
by the way I would agree with that I'm
all for you getting the Nobel Prize
which you have been nominated for six
times yeah welcome to the club with the
nominations let them but he said but
their hostilities ever happening but
their hostility to even modest curation
is a mistake does he have a point I mean
I think you and Edward Snowden are
lumped together a lot but it seems like
what his thing is is about privacy and
what your thing is about is transparency
and privacy and transparency are kind of
at loggerheads are they not they are a
little bit a little bit that's true
I suppose well he doesn't really know
the definition of curation so creation
is not censorship of the ruling
political parties our cash flows I have
I have to make a little bit of a
complaint here although I shouldn't
really go there you know Edward Snowden
hasn't published anything in three years
he did one thing it was a very important
thing and it was in fact so important
that I and this organization saved his
ass by rescuing him from Hong Kong
getting him asylum making 23 asylum
applications and setting up his defense
fund the courage Foundation which I am a
trustee of today so okay I know Edward
is trying to get a pardon at the end of
the Obama presidency and so he's you
know he's playing that game I understand
he's in a very serious situation if you
look at Chelsea Manning one of my
alleged sources sentenced to 35 years in
prison Hillary Clinton spokespersons
resigned because he was also being
tortured a formal finding by the UN is
free of fight wait Edie Loudoun in the
United States and Hillary
Clinton F Donald Trump said that he
would execute him Hillary Clinton said
of course that she would aggressively
prosecute so you have really who from
perspective of WikiLeaks trying to
protect its sources you have really two
very bad presidential candidates
well I we could go all night arguing
about that but we don't have time I
would just say in response what you said
about mr. Snowden I know you can get
into everybody's computer I don't know
if you can get into Edward Snowden's
mind but nevertheless I'm with your
brother you seem like you're in a better
state of mind than the last time I
talked to you and I hope you get out
soon thank you very much Julian I like
having a pop